[Applaudissements]
je vous proposais des choses vous me
dites que je sois ici d'accord deux
photos the voice ou nouvelle star the
voice ou nouvelle star ce que vous
pourriez faire membres d'un jury de the
voice ou nouvelle star il ya un joker ya
pas de joker à l'aise il ya un joker
well as roi un joker ouais ok non on
continue voisinera aucun des deux si si
je préfère ce bressan the voice ou es ce
que vous avez dit qu il ne serait pas
content d'être jurée dans un vase
d'aller dire moment je serais pas contre
pas contrôlé par ampatuan quoi servez
vous voudriez je trouve que c'est une
belle émission ouais c'est pas mal moi
c'est vraiment il a tué tous nous
veuille son maître gims aussi veut y est
on à la crim ce serait fort je trouve
que c'est plus pro que nouvelle star
enfin mois après mois c'est bon ça mais
c'est bien fait ça peut-être revenir
enfin la nouvelle star c'est un autre
délire c'est autre chose
mais ces petits tubes voilà c'était pas
mal aussi - voilà moi je mange des
graines de chansons anglaises donc je
comprenais rien un silo j'aime bien la
tension
booba rohff joker à la joker parce que
vous avez fait du autres bovins avec
rohff aussi bref je sais beroff il est
énervé que vous avez un double moi je
sais pas pourquoi je comprends pas moi
je sais pas moi c'est comme moi quand
sur un duo avec jean michel mr mat et de
l'envoi est énervé que je fasse un duo
tenait un appareil pour vous c'est parce
que vous aime mais vous traînez ans on
n'aurait pas dû choisir adultes et non
mais vous et vous aimez bien les deux
jokers jeunes de l'es2 attention il y
aura pas d joker à chaque fois au web
or c'est fini j'ai fini à plus de joker
au final alessandra sublet ou karine le
marchand
alessandra sublet je sais vous là qui
fait j'aime bien les votes des liens non
mais dégage quelque chose de bien
positif à rennes et charbon comme ça un
jour souriante de sylvie malépart a
ramené aussi j'aime bien moi je me bats
on peut organiser un rendez vous
j'aimerais faire sinon mais l'amitié ça
existe attention
l'amitié ça existe mais messieurs je
suis avec benhaim ça fait des années
ça fait des années que se mettre tout nu
dans ma loge il ne se passe rien aux
liens
attention jul ou gras durs gras dur
abada corps gras durs j'ai ma jeune demi
je préfère réduire ces voitures c'était
bien les deux vous avez collaboré que
les deux heures mon pote break radio on
embrasse d'ailleurs et on envoie jul
aussi que l'objectif zemmour et naulleau
ou additions et baffie a alors dit son
beau-fils cent fois je le sentais comme
ça sans fois monsieur eric naulleau il
est très sympathique
j'ai rencontré une fois mais je
préférerais de la comme marseille ou
paris
est ce que vous êtes né à paris et vous
vivez vous avez vécu à marseille ouais
j'ai grandi avec la ville tu parles où
le foot les deux je le fous dans la
merde
après ces deux cadres différents le foot
j'ai grandi avec l'om parce qu'ils ont
gagné la coupe tout ça c'est incroyable
ce que paris fait maintenant je suis de
la capitale franchement j'ai j'aime les
deux il ya des questions d'humeurs quand
la tension vendredi tout est permis ou
tp mpt pas abuser de dire tu es pmp est
pas obligé mais je te conseille quand
même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non dit la vérité quand j'étais là-bas
j'ai regardé tous les jours - l'ipod
tout ça on est tous ensemble je les
embrasse tous parce que les surprendre
regarder est bon les embrasse fort un
tout c'est vrai qu'on les embrasserait
forts et tes on pense fort à leur sens
pas très bien ton amour sans que tu dis
pas ça parce que j'ai eu à 2000% qui est
pas ça parce que je suis ton mon pote je
les aime tous m'ont essayer tous même si
en a qui sont fous ils ont leur folie à
lui même c'est ça se voit que tu les
vois pas tous les jours et voit donc te
battais pmp match quoi je vais peut te
[ __ ] dans la merde comme te dis tpm
plus j'arrête ça
[Applaudissements]